home visits are a daily routine for
linda ikeji and her colleague they're
doing outreach work for the Kenya
Medical Research Institute they've
selected certain households for malaria
testing and monitoring today's are
visiting Beatrice ok lo ok I want to
test her for malaria and anemia the
results will get the results now in
western kenya the risk of contracting
malaria is high statistics show a little
over a quarter of the population in the
region is infected the national average
is eight percent beatriz Ocala says she
and her family gets sick every couple of
weeks she sometimes visits the hospital
for treatment usually though she just
goes to the pharmacy for medication the
children are up next are testing the
health worker has good news for Beatrice
so we've just done the first response
[ __ ] malaria and the results are already
out it's negative so she has no malaria
[Music]
but Michael the youngest child tested
positive for malaria even though he
doesn't have a high fever or other
obvious symptoms due to constant
exposure to the virus he may have
developed some immunity but he still
needs to be treated cases like Michaels
are common in the region that's why the
blood samples have to be sent to the lab
for further testing in the region since
America endemic area most children who
have the pass I to them but there are no
clinical features so I can get some
sample in the lab you do the microscope
and friend they have so many facets the
laboratory at CI a-- hospital is on the
front line of the fight against malaria
in kenya researchers here study the
behavior of the malaria parasites and
test new strategies to eliminate the
virus for them cases without any obvious
symptoms represent a huge challenge so a
large proportion of the population
upwards of ninety percent of the people
who have malaria infections in their
bloodstream won't have any symptoms and
if they don't have symptoms naturally
they won't go
to a health facility to be treated
despite that they are still capable of
transmitting malaria parasites to
mosquitoes and therefore they can also
cause a problem in the transmission
cycle that's why preventing new
infections is key back in the villages
the outreach workers check the use and
condition of mosquito nets in people's
homes most people get their
insecticide-treated nets from clinics or
from the government estero who lives
here with her husband and grandchild she
says the family follows strict rules to
prevent them from contracting the
malaria virus cook alia before it's dark
and you know in the kitchen because of
the smokers room at the hospital and
feel smoke so from the kitchen we
nomadic online and even if I want to
read my Bible I read it in I've already
covered in the net in my bag although
not everyone is as diligent as Esther
olu malaria prevention awareness is
growing the hope is that safe practices
along with treatment and perhaps the
development of a suitable vaccine may
help the number of malaria cases in the
region to drop